do you think in your life a spy has  walked right by you yes right got to be  right i would say yes a spy of some type  i mean it might be a shitty spy but i do  think a spy's watching so you've been  around a spy you think  you think you've ever spoken to a spy  like speaking to my cigarettes  i think how many out of every how many  people is a spy one out of every one one  out of a million  spies are living among us in the united  states alone one expert estimates that  there are about 100 000  foreign agents what what are they  reporting back are they like hello they  are getting fatter  like what do they have to say  one in every 5 000 people's spy which  means if you go to a sell sold out  yankee game just then spend spies there  no yeah well they got to be entertained  right because you're a spy doesn't mean  you're not going to like get people too  yeah yeah yeah smiles are people too